I did like how they kind of put the one
thing I've always liked about the the
Dead uh you know the zombie games is I
love
dead risings
psychos okay okay and they kind of have
that a little bit of gear uh that's one
of the biggest thing I've always loved
is how they do the Dead Rising psychos
like where you you fight the I'll never
forget like in Dead Rising 2 where you
fight the uh the psycho in the bathroom
with the glass like they have a glass
and they're going between the Stalls and
grab you and stab you right like it's
stuff like that I really enjoy you know
and they have a little bit of that in
here addict like the most wildest I
can't don't even care you love all of us
he is too giddy over there if you if you
look at the remake of that game too like
when the cycle is moving he's cutting
himself at the same time wow he's crazy
I mean they call them cycles first